good afternoon and welcome to cast
conversations with Jay Scheib and Rianna
Flynn we'll begin with an excerpt from
world of wires directed by Jay Scheib at
MIT and 2018
a longer version of the video will be
played at the end of this conversation
[Music]
dude I think I figured out how to model
barometric pressure so let me know if
you notice like your ears popping or
anything like that
mm-hmm all right extraction phrase
nobody's here ready in three two and one
yeah
[Music]
hi hey what's up
what does stopper doing just a basic
tour you sucking some stuff yeah oh my
ears just popped crazy air pressure what
is she doing on this channel she
shouldn't be in there
[Music]
hi everyone my name is Ryan Flynn and
I'm an undergraduate student in physics
and theatre arts at MIT
today it's my pleasure to be joined by
Professor J Scheib for MIT casts three
questions series I hi thanks for Yann
and it's great to be here
my name is Jake I've as you just heard
and I'm a professor for theater arts
here at MIT I just realized that I've
been a professor for theatre arts here
now for 17 years which is kind of like a
shocker to me it's great to be here
thanks Jay so to start off the
conversation how do you use MIT and its
students to prototype and iterate your
off-campus work and what are you able to
do as a director at MIT that you might
not be able to do elsewhere okay first
question first you know I think like I
think on average in the old days on on
average I would do I would do three or
four productions in a year in the summer
especially I would make things happen
and doing them kind of kind of all over
the US and print but primarily in Europe
and so at MIT my courses would
ultimately be like an extension of my
research process and so I would develop
classes or seminars that would kind of a
line with whatever productions that
might happen to have on horizon and
whenever possible I would
to develop aspects of the work on campus
and I've always found it to be like a
super rich process to work with students
in need not in that process world of
wires the excerpt that we just saw is a
was an example of that sort of thing
yeah in terms of like what I can do at
MIT that can't be done elsewhere that's
like a super long list because it's
definitely not every every theater
company in the world where you can sort
of stroll down the hall and you know
bump into someone from aero-astro for
example so being being constantly
confronted with entirely different ways
of thinking in ways of seeing and
comprehending the world is something
that really can't be duplicated anywhere
else I mean so that that kind of level
of interdisciplinarity is you know
shockingly important to me yeah I've
definitely seen how you've collaborated
with people in our last row or other
departments and it's been incredible to
see the work that's come out of that J
and the two classes I've taken with you
at MIT I've greatly enjoyed the times
when you brought in your professional
collaborators to teach like many master
classes and I've loved being able to
work with your professional
collaborators on projects like the
silence I like to combine MIT students
with your usual collaborators and could
you speak to how you bring these
collaborators into your teaching well so
a lot of a lot of what a lot of what
I've been obsessed with over the years
has to do with working in working in
theatre or in opera which are which are
to like really really old art forms and
also sometimes incredibly conservative
art forms art forms with big walls
around them especially opera and I've
always been quite obsessed with bringing
you know other disciplines to bear
on these potentially really conservative
forms and that means that often I'm
often I'm working with people who have
wildly different skill sets and so it's
um it's it's really kind of an
invaluable thing to bring someone like
to bring a cinematographer for instance
like Pauline intrinsic who you met but
bringing her from outside I would
usually only work with her in various
theatrical productions but bringing her
to the classroom allows everyone to
basically like get a perspective that's
like really different from mine and and
learn new tricks you know so I find I
find that I find that it's just a really
expansive experience any and following
on your the second part of your question
[Music]
bringing you know incorporating like
gonna work like the silence so we
adapted in Mark Bergman's
film The Silence to a sort of live
cinema performance which we prototyped
in like - I really like fast and furious
weeks and it was a mixture of students
and faculty and and Profis from you know
around the country who participated now
there was a time when I would do this
sort of thing that where I would think
oh gosh I need to like kind of like
protect the students like not give them
too much not like put them at the center
of the thing not like not put them in a
position where I don't know they might
have a bad experience or feels somehow
like they weren't able to keep up
whatever and that's probably true at
some some schools that might be a good
strategy but I've found that at MIT most
of our students that would totally like
not even like allow that to happen
so it's been exciting to just like throw
people in and you know the the result of
that kind of attitude is that
students rise to the occasion everyone
tends to be like incredibly generous
because there's this like you know great
like energy in the room from from the
students and that and the combination is
I think really quite electric and and as
a result I've ended up touring with
students that I worked with to places
like the Walker Art Center to Hungary to
New York really although all of it all
over the place so that's um that's
really a great great symbiotic
relationship and I and in the end
everyone gets something from it yeah I
definitely enjoyed acting as camera
operator on the silence when you just
kind of threw me in there and had me
with no camera experience just start
operating a camera experience and by the
way you shot it beautifully Jay in your
work you often experience the
intersection of the real and the virtual
and given that technology is
increasingly acting as such a direct
performance interface how does the
cutting edge research at MIT that you've
been involved in manifest in your art I
think the biggest the biggest aspect or
the the biggest impact that being at MIT
has had on my sort of engagement with
technology in what was otherwise a super
analog art form is it's just to be kind
of fearless about it and to you know and
to go ahead and like ask questions that
you know at first glance don't make
sense
you know like does it make sense for an
audience of 2,000 people in an opera
house to all wear you know goggles
probably not so we should try and I
think I'm in a way like MIT has taught
me to think like that for sure but it's
also given me an opportunity to
I think in a way it vary quite
incrementally so the ways in which I've
worked with cameras over the years has
continually like grown and expanded and
and I kind of like focus in a studio
practice on taking one step after
another and I'm now in the process of
trying to figure out to what degree I
can use the volumetric volumetric
videography in order to create an
entirely different sets of sense of
liveness I'm no longer using cameras but
actually measures but actually capturing
motion and light and finding ways to
speed that up to you know to to
real-time so in a way like I don't think
I ever I probably would have never even
heard of volumetric filmmaking until it
had become mainstream had I not been in
the halls of MIT so it's a you know it's
a it's kind of a perfect relationship
can you speak to any upcoming work that
you're doing that involves you you
alluded to it in talking about 2,000
people in an opera house with goggles on
can you speak more to that um yeah well
I can and I can't I guess it hasn't been
it hasn't been announced because now
everything has been postponed but um I
had fun let's just say I have two
projects on the horizon both of which
will both of which have have offered me
an opportunity to set a really high
challenge which is to find a way to make
use of AR VR technology and performance
so augmented reality virtual reality and
and some combination of the two let's
that we call extended reality
so I you know I've been I've been sort
of toying around with them starting a
group called an extended performance
sonography group where where we would
sort of foam take on the prospect of
real-time effects processing and you
know real-time you know using laser
scanners in in completely different ways
in order to develop performances and I
and I'm going to bring this this
research to bear on a couple of major
operas in the next few years I think
that's all I'm allowed to say about that
particular project but yeah so I'm
working on a partner operon I'm
wondering has coronavirus and its
implications for in a social distancing
and the use of technology to be having
to use technology to interact with each
other has that influenced your
perception or thinking about all these
techniques that you use in your work at
all um yeah it has for sure I I think
that I think we have an imperative in a
way to like try to figure out how to use
the tools that we have to bridge the
distances we do it pretty much
automatically all the time right but but
there's something about them there's
something about a live event that you
know I don't know does it for us in a
way like when you're in a room with
someone who's performing it's um it's
just a very different experience than if
you're say watching a film or even
watching a you know a video conference
call but somehow somehow finding a way
to make technology bridge the distances
is an imperative and I can't think of a
better place than MIT to try to figure
that out you know we still don't know
when large assembly art forms will
you know come out of the come out of the
out of the basement you know like right
now we're all kind of sheltered so it's
hard to say when that will happen again
like when we're going to have 2,000
people I don't know how to tour him it
may be that these that these 2,000
people will need to feel like they're in
the auditorium and so you know I'm very
excited by developments in like
olfactory AR other kinds of things which
would really give you a sense of being
there even even though you're not and
hopefully without the depression that
you when you realize that you're
actually not there yeah where are you
you're in yeah I remember you saying
once about how you know when you watch
sports on TV it's more live than live
because when you go into the stadium and
actually like see them you're you're so
far away and everything seems like it's
not as live because when you see it on
TV
and I think your work definitely is
trying to get at that more live than
live kind of yeah somehow you know
somehow the prospect of like actually
having something live when you're when
you amplifying it is is quite it's quite
different when there's no when there's
no like they're there or whether there
is scattered around the world you know
because we can put together a group of a
group of performers and maybe we will in
the fall because I'll make a production
in the fall with them MIT students and
the expectation is that well we don't
know where things will be in the fall
but in the in the odd in the odd chance
that that we have to be somehow like
practicing social distancing in the fall
we will find a way to make the
production anyway
using whatever means of whatever
technology is we can hack together at
the time so we'll see more live in live
we're live to live even when it's not
yeah thank you so much J for taking the
time to have this conversation with me
today
and thank you to everyone who joined us
for this webinar and thank you to cast
for giving us the opportunity to have
this conversation and now I'd like to
turn it back over to Kathryn thank you
thank you both and thanks everyone for
joining us for this conversation with
Jake I've Andry on plan please visit art
Stott mit.edu from anywhere for a wide
range of arts activities online
exhibitions and performances research
and more and before ending this
broadcast I will play a longer excerpt
from world of wires at MIT and 2018 have
a wonderful weekend everyone bye
hey you can't sleep dude I think I
figured out how to bottle barometric
pressure so let me know if you notice
like your ears popping or anything like
that mm-hmm all right
extraction phrase nobody's here ready in
three two and one
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
hi hey what's up
what is stopper doing just a basic tour
you checking some stuff yeah oh my ears
just popped crazy air pressure what is
she doing on this channel she shouldn't
be in there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
five [ __ ] minutes
Lydia open a [ __ ] window it smells
like smoke in here hands where I can see
them going down now now do it now gun
down basis
plastic oh wow we need a paramedic bring
in the burn unit oh hey sue me sue me
I'll be fine I promise you okay I'll
save you I just wanna see me oh my god
he's losing a lot of blood get the gun
come on
hysterics tell me that problem and
Langston's clear but the protocol known
no exit wound - administer CPR 1 2 3 4 5
come on please yeah forget it he's gone
[Applause]
a great simulation well those those
unbelievable those so real holy [ __ ]
yeah maybe that was a little bit too
read no no this is exactly where we're
going more hard that's what they want
and we can give it to them a lot of
things that should have started out as
jokes okay the fact is that when you
finally succeed at putting machines
inside of people who find themselves
living inside of machines you're going
to have to embrace some some pretty
heavy thinking about the fundamental
nature of both machines and people
I knew it it's green it's possible I
switched your consciousness with my
husband I don't know it's true you know
it's like waking up from a videogame
it's like playing Grand Theft Auto and
then realizing that the grand theft auto
car is parked in your driveway and like
grand theft auto girl it's still right
there right next to you and you can just
reach out and touch her I'm here
you
[Music]